So, to emphasize good programming style, here's a quiz. Why do we prefer version
A, where we used the named arguments, over version B, where we didn't? And these
two produce exactly the same thing. We can use format string with just using
squiggles with no names. It's just going to use the arguments passed in, in
order. The choices are, longer is better, and A is longer. If we make a mistake
and use the wrong parameter name by using named parameters like we did in A, we
would get an error. For example, if we used value here instead of price, these
wouldn't match up and this would lead to a parameter error. With version B,
there's no names so there's nothing to match, so there wouldn't be any error.
For the third choice, the names make it easier for others to read and understand
the code. Check all the good reasons why we would prefer A over B.